mar a lago allanada la mansión del
expresidente de donald trump en florida
fue registrada por el fbi una inspección
que responde a una investigación que
busca esclarecer si el mandatario se
llevó y eliminó documentos clasificados
de la casablanca y detonó el enojo del
republicano estos son tiempos oscuros
para nuestra nación ya que mi hermosa
casa marc halago en palm beach florida
se encuentra actualmente sitiada
allanada y ocupada por un gran grupo de
agentes del fbi nunca antes le había
pasado algo así a un presidente de los
eeuu
15 cajas con documentos clasificados
habrían sido trasladadas por el
mandatario y por lo cual el fbi obtuvo
una orden de allanamiento el lunes por
la mañana un operativo que no se cruzó
con el expresidente que se encontraba en
nueva york no es la primera vez que
trump es investigado por violar la ley
de registros presidenciales de 1978 que
estipula la obligación de preservar los
documentos de la casa blanca en la casa
blanca pero el allanamiento de este
lunes fue inédito
el expresidente aseguró que responde a
intereses políticos
ahora mientras ven a los candidatos que
respaldó obtener grandes victorias y ven
mi dominio en todas las encuestas están
tratando de detenerme a mí y al partido
republicano una vez más la anarquía la
persecución política y la caza de brujas
deben ser expuestas y detenidas
el operativo se da cuando los
reflectores están puestos sobre el
republicano trump se encuentra planeando
lanzarse a una nueva carrera
presidencial en 2024 al mismo tiempo en
que otra investigación en curso que nos
que esclarecer la responsabilidad de
trump en el ataque del 6 de enero al
capitolio